barthelemy nd arbeitet als
altenpflegehelfer in der
senioreneinrichtung johannesstift der
kameruner kam 2014 nach deutschland und
hat eine arbeitserlaubnis was er an
jenem samstag den 18 april nicht weiß er
ist mit dem corona virus infiziert am
selben tag wird die gesamte
flüchtlingsunterkunft hennigsdorf wo er
wohnt unter quarantäne gestellt da immer
polizei um die gas ich darf man muss
immer im zimmer bleiben wo man kann
nicht rausgehen
ja das war die die größe stress aus dem
heim ruft er seine chefin an sagt dass
er nicht zur arbeit kommen kann
erst drei tage später am dienstag 21
april wird er auf corona getestet das
ergebnis ist positiv dass wagen extrem
glücklicher zustand dass er
verantwortungsvoll sich gemeldet hat und
wir dadurch letzten endes nur zwei
positive fälle bei bewohnern hatten in
der einrichtung die auch völlig
komplikationslos verlief angesteckt hat
er sich höchstwahrscheinlich in der
flüchtlingsunterkunft hier hat sich
jeder fünfte mitbewohner infiziert
bisher der altenpflegehelfer war in
einem zweibettzimmer untergebracht und
bietet sie mal nicht abstellen waren auf
diese zustände wie es bereits zwei
wochen zuvor am 9 april simone tetzlaff
von der flüchtlingsberatung hin
sie forderte den zuständigen landkreis
zum handeln auf es war ja klar dass sich
eben in diesen sammelunterkünften
es sich einfach nicht organisieren lässt
dass menschen sich vor dem virus
schützen
abstands gebote sind definitiv nicht
einzuhalten
sie schlug vor geflüchtete die in
systemrelevanten berufen arbeiten statt
in sammelunterkünften in leerstehenden
pensionen unterzubringen
dafür ist der landkreis oberhavel
zuständig ein interview lehnen die
verantwortlichen ab schriftlich heißt es
zitat eine verteilung von bewohnerinnen
und bewohnern auf andere standorte war
und ist nicht geplant
dabei wollte die gesundheitsministerin
flüchtlinge dezentral unterbringen es
blieb eine empfehlung mein ministerium
hat schon frühzeitig die kommunen
entsprechend angeschrieben und darauf
hingewiesen jetzt in der korona pandemie
das für entzerrung zu sorgen ist in
großen gemeinschaftsunterkünften das für
ausweichquartiere sorge zu tragen ist
aber das wird nun nicht innerhalb von
drei wochen gerade wenn wir in einer
corona pandemie stecken zu erreichen
sein
in der flüchtlingsunterkunft in
hennigsdorf sind bisher 84 bewohner
positiv getestet worden in mehr als 40
asylunterkünften in deutschland gibt es
corona fälle besonders hoch sind die
zahlen in bremen mit mindestens 200
infizierten in sankt augustin 179 in
ellwangen 406 und im bayerischen
geldersheim mit 137 infizierten
münchen flüchtlinge aus ganz bayern und
ihre unterstützer demonstrieren ende mai
[Musik]
und je länger wir in diesen unterkünften
unter diesen bedingungen bleiben dass du
mehr wird sich krone ausbreiten weil wir
uns nicht schützen können
sie sammeln unterschriften ihre
forderung große asylunterkünfte auflösen
immer wieder wird berichtet dass in
zahlreichen unterkünften nicht einmal
ausreichend seife und
desinfektionsmittel zur verfügung
gestellt werden
für menschen die in deutschland schutz
suchen bedeutet die unterbringung in
massenunterkünften in zeiten von kobe 19
die schaffung von lebensgefährlichen
umständen wir treffen den virologen
gerhard schwarzkopf steinhauser er
kritisiert seit langem die zustände in
den asylunterkünften und hat mit anderen
ärzten an die bayerische regierung
geschrieben mein vorwurf ist dass die
quasi die menschen die dort wohnen dem
schicksal von diesem virus überlassen
und von denen die sich infizieren wird
ein teil erkranken und ein teil davon
wird aufgrund ihrer situation auch
versterben und dies nimmt diese
regierung in kauf und das ist nicht
akzeptabel das bayerische
innenministerium lehnt ein interview ab
bestreitet die vorwürfe
infizierte würden strikt separiert heißt
das zitat mit diesen maßnahmen wird
einerseits die übrige bevölkerung vor
der ausbreitung des virus geschützt aber
genauso die dort isoliert
untergebrachten asylbewerber vor
gegenseitiger ansteckung
dennoch sind in bayern bisher vier
asylbewerber an cholera gestorben die in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften gelebt haben
einer von ihnen hat hier gewohnt an der
aschauer straße in münchen
wir nennen ihn hamid in solch einem
zweimann zimmer war er untergebracht in
der gemeinschaftsküche hat hamid mit
anderen bewohnern gekocht und sich
wahrscheinlich dort mit corona
angesteckt
diese flüchtlings betreuerin kannte
hamid seit 2005 10
die ehrenamtliche will unerkannt bleiben
aus angst vor anfeindungen
sie hatte mitgeholfen in deutschland fuß
zu fassen und einen job in einer
konditorei zu finden sehr freundliche
und höfliche sehr zurückhaltender mensch
derweil total gut integriert hat vom
ersten tag an deutschkurse gemacht und
konnte dann arbeiten hat vier jahre voll
gearbeitet als ganztags kraft es ist
freitag der dritte april
hamit hat fieber und kopfschmerzen
informiert die unterkunfts leitung ein
arzt telefoniert mit ihm sieht jedoch
keinen handlungsbedarf er geht von
leichten symptomen aus montag sechster
april hamid ruft seine bekannte an kann
vor husten kaum sprechen und er hatte
weitere symptome geschmacks störungen
geruch weg und dann habe ich ab da
gleich ob dem montagmorgen gleich ein
alarm geschlagen dass da einer schwerer
krank ist
sie ruft bei der bayerischen corona
hotline an die wiederum informiert das
münchner gesundheitsreferat per mail
verdachtsfall mit hohem fieber luftnot
halsschmerzen die aufforderung umgehend
tätig zu werden
dienstag siebter april die ehrenamtliche
schreibt hamid eine sms
guten morgen wie geht es dir hast du
noch hohes fieber guten morgen ich bin
nicht so gut aber ich habe noch nicht
probleme mit luft holen es ist ein
bisschen zu viel husten arzt noch nicht
da
fünf tage legt hamid mittlerweile krank
im bett
wir fragen das bayerische
innenministerium ob die behörden zu spät
reagiert haben
antwort zitat wenn ein mensch nur
leichte symptome ähnlich einem schnupfen
hat kommt er in kein krankenhaus sondern
kuriert sich daheim aus das gilt auch
für asylbewerber am dienstagnachmittag
kommt ein arzt und testet auf coruna er
habe es aber abgelehnt ins krankenhaus
gebracht zu werden teilt die regierung
von oberbayern mit die die unterkunft
betreibt offenbar schätzte hamid seinen
gesundheitszustand besser ein als er
tatsächlich war donnerstag neunter april
hamid schreibt seiner bekannten einer
sms hallo danke für alle
ich bin gut arzt war schon es war die
letzte nachricht die sie von hamid
bekommen hat freitag zehnter april hamid
wird mit dem rettungswagen ins münchner
klinikum rechts der isar gebracht er
wird beatmet liegt im koma 14 tage
später ist er tot
ich habe kenntnisse von kollegen im
rechts der isar die schildern dass der
patient viel zu spät ins krankenhaus
eingewiesen worden ist und quasi schon
unter intensivmedizinischen bedingungen
und unmittelbar auf die intensivstation
gekommen ist jetzt ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen wegen
fahrlässiger tötung zurück ins altenheim
zurück zur barthélémy ndr hat corona
überstanden darf wieder arbeiten jetzt
bekommt er ein eigenes zimmer im
seniorenstift im prinzip hätten wir
genau genommen diesen schritt schon
vorher machen sollen um ihnen auch
vielleicht vor der infektion zu schützen
gut die lernkurve im rahmen dieser
pandemie ist bei allen
maaßen steil angestiegen so dass wir
erst jetzt angebot aussprechen
ja ich finde schön weil das ist ein
bisschen sicherheit für mich und von
kollege ungewohnt für ihn ist die zeit
in der asylunterkunft vorbei tausende
andere aber riskieren dort weiterhin
ihre gesundheit tag für tag